so i'm entering the ice road
i have to take off my
safety belts
this is probably the only road in canada
where you're not allowed to wear
your safety belts it's a lot safer
in case something happens on the road
to not be wearing uh
your seat belts
so yeah this is the
beginning of the ice road
just coming off the ingram trail
and as you can see it's quite wide
we'll be getting to a bit of land here
and then at some point
i'll be entering the big lake
so this is uh tibet lake
as you can see there the speed limit for
trucks
is 25 kilometers an hour
i'm driving a pickup truck
so i can go a bit faster
but i'm gonna stay in this lane
and
go really slowly for now
so this is
this is it this is the ice rod
this is the half kilometer marker
this is to help the trucks
to keep
a half a kilometer distance
and this is what they do
they have to travel in convoys of at
least
two
up four
and they have to keep a distance of
500 meters from each other for safety
reasons
so and to prevent
the ice from breaking up
underneath them
you see my seat belt
wants to be on but i'll have to deal
with this for the next couple of hours
while i'm on the ice room
my speed right now is 40 kilometers an
hour
uh imagine the truck drivers
cannot go uh faster than 25 kilometers
an hour
as you can see
the ice cracks
and apparently it's a good thing because
it allows
the ice to peel
so this is a problem uh lake area
it's a area where i guess ice is not
very good
and so
that's why all traffic has to
reduce
speed and as you can see further in here
the speed limit on this lake is
15
kilometers an hour
for trucks
oh
you